there is a story just came out of mexico
that is
really really jarring and should put all
americans on high alert for what it
means
for our own culture because it's coming
here as well
a university student in mexico
is the the school's valedictorian
okay he's got now his
degree and license to practice
psychology
and now all of that is threatened his
degree his license to practice his
career is threatened
because the valedictorian
had the audacity to challenge
transgender theory and to defend the
family
so this guy in his speech
in his
valedictory speech makes a really
important basic but really important
point he says
i'll
translate into english
today we are deep into a real
anthropological struggle to redefine the
human being the human person man through
the implementation of ideologies and
fashions of thought that always end up
undermining dignity and freedom
he then quoted gk chesterton
he said people do not know what they are
doing because they do not know what they
are undoing and then he said to attack
life in the family is to self-destruct
it is an attack on civilization itself
absolutely true he's right
and now he could lose everything adf the
alliance defending freedom which i
strongly support is now defending this
young man this is coming here too and
what this really represents
is effectively an outlawing of
christianity in public life
and coincidentally an outlying of
judaism and public life and
coincidentally an outlawing of islam and
public life and coincidentally an
outlawing of any vaguely traditional
religious moral ethical view on marriage
that's what it is it's an it's an
establishment of
leftism as the state religion
you're seeing it in mexico you're seeing
it elsewhere in latin america you're
seeing it all throughout western europe
and you're seeing it happen in the
united states this is what the marriage
bill is about i mentioned it a little
briefly at the end of the show yesterday
there's a bill right now
that's being supported by democrats and
squish republicans
republicans in the senate and even some
senate candidates are volunteering this
like dr oz the biggest loser running
this year he's saying i'm going to
defend this bill that will not only
accept the supreme court's decision to
radically redefine marriage in
obergefell but it's going to enshrine
that in federal law and by the way even
if you support a burglar even if you
support redefining marriage to include
same-sex unions
the bill goes much further than that
what the bill does is effectively outlaw
institutions that have any relation to
the government at all from believing
that marriage is what marriage actually
is and not the insane new definition of
it
what what the marriage bill will do
is say that if you're uh if you're a
501c3 if you're a church if you're a
civic organization if that you if and
you
in any way support marriage as marriage
actually is
you're going to lose your your tax
exemption you're going to be punished by
the state you're going to be sued by the
government they already did this in
pennsylvania they did this because a
catholic charity what a catholic charity
uh helps facilitate the adoption of
children and because it's a catholic
charity it doesn't adopt children out to
just anybody it says that children have
a right to a mother and a father and so
the the babies go to
married
parents you know husband and wife
uh some gay activists sued and said no
we want the children and we want to
force the catholic adoption agency to
give children to us goes up to the high
courts
and finally
uh the the courts say no sorry
pennsylvania sorry political activists
in the pennsylvania government you don't
have the right to ban catholicism from
your state this law would do it
this law would do it and it's not even
just this one bill you're seeing it's
not even just this one country you're
seeing it in mexico too if you even
suggest that maybe we shouldn't redefine
the human person and the family oh yeah
you remember how you were the smartest
person in our class remember you're the
valedictorian you have a great career
ahead of you we're going to take it all
away we're going to take it all away
because you have the audacity
to be a christian or a jew or a muslim
or just a reasonable person or
you have the audacity to hold the views
on marriage and the human person that
barack obama held in 2011.
that's the stakes that we're talking
about and you've got
useless coward
morally idiotic republicans
some of them it's a small minority but
it's some of them who are defending it
it's pathetic
the question we're asking ourselves is
not well who has the right who has the
right to get married or adopt or this or
the right to speak or your right to not
be offended or this right or that right
of this right really the question is
what is the animating
force of our country
what is the soul of our country that's
what we're really asking countries have
a physical aspect and a
metaphysical aspect just like a human
person we got our body and we got our
soul well the country is the same way so
what is
what is the what is america what we are
told today by the libs is that america
is a liberal democracy we need to defend
liberal democracy and what's really
ironic about this
is that the phrase liberal democracy
appears pretty much nowhere
in the english language until really
until 1930 and then it doesn't spike at
all until really the 1950s and then it
really doesn't take off until 1982 but
before if you if you google say
christian nation
that appears all over the place
christian civilization christian country
that's all over the literature you can
see it everywhere liberal democracy
doesn't exist it doesn't really take off
until about 40 years ago
so if if liberal democracy is what
america really is at her core at her
essence
no one knew it until roughly four
decades ago
the way that america conceived herself
in the beginning
the constitution the declaration of
independence the federalist papers you
don't see that phrase liberal democracy
you don't see the phrase democracy all
that much democracy does not appear in
the constitution or the declaration of
independence it does appear in the
federalist papers a handful of times
always with disapproval
the founding fathers were very very
skeptical of democracy and the word
liberal doesn't really appear it doesn't
appear in the constitution doesn't
appear in the declaration of
independence it appears in the
federalist again a handful of times but
only in the sense of
generous you know he's a very liberal
person it's not referring to any
political philosophy or ideology
by contrast
the word nation
appears in all three of the documents it
appears in the federalist papers i think
569 times always with approval and then
so at the physical aspect you see okay
america's a nation
and then what animates the nation what's
the soul of the nation it's not
liberalism if you go back to the
founding documents the founding papers
it's christianity that's what john adams
says john adams says that the thing that
united the founding fathers the thing
that united the men who built the
country was the principles of
christianity that's it sometimes the
libs like to quote this line that they
pretend is from john adams they say
america is in no way founded on the
christian religion that line comes from
the treaty of tripoli that was signed by
john adams but it was not written by
john adams it was written by the
jeffersonian republican joel barnow i
think his name was and it was it was
just a diplomatic document to placate
the muslim pirates who were abducting
and enslaving american sailors
it was like a ransom letter basically it
wasn't a statement of philosophy or even
really law and john adams when he was
speaking freely and not trying to ransom
back the sailors directly contradicted
the treaty of tripoli and we all know
this we know that america was a
christian nation going back to its
earliest days 1620 the mayflower why did
the pilgrim set sail on the mayflower to
establish christianity
in the new world why did governor
winthrop establish the massachusetts bay
colony you don't need to scratch your
head we know he told us because he gave
us a speech in which he said that
america will be a shining city on a hill
and a model of christian charity
we see this in the writings of the
founding fathers we see this
later on in american history we see this
in the francis scott keys poem
you know the star spangled banner is
based on this poem called the battle of
fort mchenry and the final stanza of it
no one ever remembers the stanza but the
final big conclusion of the poem is oh
thus be it ever when free men shall
stand between their loved home and the
war is desolation blessed with victory
and peace may the heaven rescue the land
praise the power that hath made and
preserved us a nation then conquer we
must when our cause is just and this be
our motto in god is our trust and the
star-spangled banner and triumph shall
wave or the land of the free and the
home of the brave
in god is our trust
so that poem became the national anthem
it was authorized for military use in
the late 19th century it's acknowledged
for official use by the white house in
1916 i believe and then established as
the national anthem in 1931 with the
approval of the president as well so
with the congress and the president this
is our national anthem this is our
national motto and god is our trust
eisenhower added a version of that to
the pledge of allegiance one nation
under god and we know that in god in god
we trust is on all of the us currency
okay that's the animating principle all
a long way of saying what is
america it's a christian
nation
the body of america it's not
it's not just an empire it's not a
city-state the physical aspect of
america is a nation
okay that's what the founders
established
and then the spiritual aspect the
metaphysical aspect the thing that
animates the nation just like the soul
animates the body a body without a soul
is dead a nation without an animating
principle is dead the animating
principle is not liberalism it's not
secularism it's not atheism
traditionally it's christianity that's
what it is it's just i'm not even saying
that's a good thing or a bad thing i
obviously think it is a good thing i'm
just stating in historical fact that is
irrefutable okay
and now there is a major campaign
underway to upend all of that what the
libs want to do is destroy america as a
nation and open up its borders a nation
that doesn't have borders cannot be a
nation at all they want to turn america
into basically just a tax farm for a
global empire and make us all citizens
of the world without any distinction
between our people and other people
but again a nation that does not make
any distinction between its own citizens
and foreign nationals is not a nation
there's there's nothing that
distinguishes it as a nation and then at
the metaphysical level what the
democrats want to do is disestablish
christianity
as the animating principle of the
country and establish atheism or
secularism or leftism or whatever
the consequences of that are terrible
the reason that the libs are complaining
about christian nationalism right now i
just gave a long talk on this at the
national conservative conference which
you can find on youtube
the reason that the democrats are losing
their minds over christian nationalism
is not because it's a departure from the
american political tradition
they're losing their minds over it
because christian nationalism is the
american political tradition
the libs hate the american political
tradition and they're trying to upend
the whole thing right now go to ring.com
knowles we are in speech season baby i
travel a whole lot i
yeah but i'm always traveling a lot you
might be too you got your summer
vacations then you're going back to work
and then you want to make sure that your
home is protected that's why you need
ring did you know that ring has a
wonderful alarm system i know you're
thinking ring the video doorbell company
yeah they have an alarm they have an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe best of all you can easily
install it yourself and ring does not
stop there
they've changed the entire home security
game with ring alarm pro that is why i
have teamed up with ring and when it
comes to protecting our home you got to
go pro baby you got to be a pro like me
okay ring alarm pro is whole home
security
with available professional monitoring
when you subscribe to ring protect pro
ring alarm pro combines a security
system with a fast euro wi-fi 6 router
so you're protecting your physical home
and your digital home as well all with
one device it's absolutely phenomenal
protect your home be like me go pro with
ring alarm pro so you can do it too okay
learn more at ring.com
knowles that is ring.com
knowles i'm so glad you like that clip
now
i need you to ring that bell please
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you